sorry I've hired a new a comic and he
was doing a podcast a while ago and it's
very strange because if though so
everyone was trying to get him fired
from planet life because he did this old
bit on a podcast for about agents and
it's night it's like I watched I'm like
God man that's it it's didn't this this
this culture we're in this toxic culture
here and what bothers me it's some other
comics month this is ridiculous get them
fired have you seen Sam Tripoli going up
people online yeah Sam's like get the
file remember this [ __ ] you guys
want to screw this guy over biggest day
of his life and Anthony Jeselnik had the
best thing goes oh I'm so happy to see
when a comic has one of the biggest days
of his life someone tried to [ __ ] bring
him down yeah guys win now yeah but have
you seen it it you have you have you
guys watched it mmm they might bring up
Shang Gilles you can fly with it what
were the comp contra what was the joke
about it he went to Asian restaurant how
hard is to order you should see it I
watched on it I see way more Dicer stuff
and then never how about how about
[ __ ] a dead Dave Chappelle hunting
that I he was like talking about being
Chinese I'm Chinese now remember yep I
remember that you I mean we're so
ridiculous now but but it's all I
guarantee spine not even Asians it's
probably white people gone we're - were
were laws don't try to tone that's
that's the one I think that got him in
trouble you watched that that out that
again I don't know all of it but I know
that's I watched that that was what was
on Twitter so go to that one and you got
as Asian Americans telling you this
offend you so that's him there just
gotta get you sound like biggest deal
ever forgot started they just built one
[ __ ] up looking building and people
are like alright no one said anything
looks live there well they built these
[ __ ] like huge Shanghai out the first
one the chinks come what are you saying
that's how they were thinking hey you
know what yeah true also I'm always like
how can there be so many [ __ ]
restaurants down here all roses you
going there's like one person
idiots like me or than their true
up-and-down neuters I hate I hate the
food at China's house sucks Chinese
foods are very dishonest cuisine
I don't they invented a [ __ ] chemical
to put in their food to make it
delicious dude they made us a msg it's
dishonest food dude there's nothing
there's nothing to it it's shitty shitty
meat a chemical they made up to [ __ ]
your body up and noodles neuters see the
biggest promise a terrible policy in the
world keep going chemical cuz you'll
hear everything you can find we got in
there and we sat down and this is my
camera I'm so excited for new ders
and I was like yo chill chill she said
neuters ya [ __ ] yeah and it's it's
[ __ ] shiny in there is that kind of
like nice though it's not being one when
people go into legal maximum restaurant
like I'll to tacos on the bowl of spicy
neuters but we had in the translation
between you and the waiter yeah it's
just such a [ __ ] hassle it's like and
you I'm pointing it lets me put number
if like 57 yeah this one even with the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay point I was like that sauce yeah
that's it that that was our in my office
is here we know what he's saying there's
no way this why they want to find no
daddy said let me hear God says [ __ ] I
wonder how that started they just built
one [ __ ] up looking building and
people are like all right no one said
anything so he's referring to other
people that's right I mean I don't think
it's seen that is where people scroll
but can you google it has to be
something else there's no way you won't
get them fired from Santa's library
there's no way it's crazy
Shane Chinese oh [ __ ] that's
resurface to us the communities heard
using rich surrogates see that that's it
yeah Shane's secret Chinese
[ __ ] nuts he says at one point in the
conversation just since been deleted let
the [ __ ] chinks live there yeah
honestly it's that's it dude yeah I
wouldn't care Wow cat I don't my biggest
thing is I don't think it was a very
good podcast I don't think it's anything
to get in arms about I mean I hear
somebody over I mean yeah
oh no they're calling for his job you
know what Lorne Michaels is doing
nothing good for him
Thank You Lauren so town team is calm
Thank You Lauren I thought they said
they fired him though did they fire no
way over that oh yeah he's don't [ __ ]
he's out oh no way Wow [ __ ] you oh my
[ __ ] yeah that was 40 minutes ago yeah
Wow Wow
because I'm a podcast let's see if he
was fart if he's just not doing it
that's right mostly at virtual history
I've talked with Shane Gillis we have
decided that he will not be joining
Center life whence a bright voice we are
not aware of his prior remarks that have
surfaced over the past few days the
language he heard is offensive hurtful
rock you rock you that's that's amazing
I feel it feels ridiculous for me to be
making serious public statements but
here we are I'm a community was funny
enough together that can't be taken away
of course I wanted an opportunity to
prove himself of this no but I
understand it would be too much for a
distraction you know what I feel bad for
Shane Gillis he put I was always a mad
guy always a mad TV guy anyway haha [ __ ]
man I feel bold my job bad for that guy
he lost but this count this cancel
culture that we live in yeah so who's
also so so this is what happens you get
you lose your [ __ ] the biggest
opportunity of your life because you are
making an offhand comment about what
other people say and you were saying
it's true it's true you go down a good
China town and the guy doesn't speak
English at all and you you know there's
gonna be confusions it's saying the word
chinks which come in trouble
he was saying that's what people that
would that was that's that's what people
say oh my god it doesn't mean he's
racist you're not dealing with a racist
here
you know it wasn't funny though that's
like if he can't pointed out before too
it's like he wasn't funny that wasn't
funny but it doesn't matter but but how
deep are we gonna go for this guy to
Bruno I don't think he should be fired
Saturday night I dived I mean wow good
luck getting on ass now you I'm screwed
never happen my dream out is what this
is what I mean that's like it honey just
create your own world [ __ ]
corporations like Google corporations
like and that's now now and NBC's they
are so afraid they're so afraid to even
be nuanced about things oddly it's
saying they fold to the [ __ ]
pressure it's not even pressure they
fold to this horseshit noise on Twitter
no hold on hold on listen this [ __ ]
on here goes it should go without saying
but Gil stream might remains a popular
profitable commune who has under no
definite net definition been cancelled
if history has any indication he stands
a game from his notoriety I hope he does
at least Sam these people are talking
about him I'm sure he's a good comic you
know what's a great comic you know it's
a bummer is other comics one after him
really yeah what are the comics that you
guys know yeah oh that sucks I don't
know you know I'm sure you guys could
Google later no no one in our circle who
are they Diana Schumer no no you bring
it up bring up I don't I don't be part
of that god imagine gets the biggest
call your life on satellite life the
biggest call and then a few days later
people go dude that podcast she did
however [ __ ] long ago that time
you've referenced jinx you're not
getting on that life Wow these are these
Jimmy o yang cuz he's a he's an Asian
Comics comic I'm on the same bill of all
the time he's a great comic he put his
Caminos you side with comedians on thin
subjects but this is just plain racist
it's truly disgusting stand up against
this is just as important to support our
Asian brothers and sisters see a lion
has to go I'm not Chinese I'll both say
this I've said this is yeah that's a
Chinese Chinese people in this country
have dealt with our fuckload of racism
and a fuckload of violence and I like a
way more than people know they just have
they don't they just don't voice it but
there is no question that that shot
people of Chinese descent ethnic Chinese
all over the world have done incredibly
well in every culture them immersed
himself in because their culture
frugality and all that and and and hard
work and all that but they have dealt
without fuckload not only of prejudice
but but but like literal massacres let
me ask you right I mean usually on the
show you Gilles is racist no but I know
that's my point I understand people's
sensitivity but I what shame kills here
was doing was referencing how other
people were talking about that in a very
offhand comment and to take it away I
got a problem
even when Daniel D Kim says this he's
not seen in the same context he was
asked to be a joke in there somewhere
he's reference is awful podcasting the
contents not good
firing from having a bot bad podcast not
for being racist scroll up who's the
other comic w come on girl - no Bell
goes hard I'm a bell fan who is that
he's on CNN here's a shot in really come
on Bell is brilliant man at CNN he's I
really like him so what's he saying
that's it's a joke that's already been
done and yeah I don't make those Joe
comics in TV III don't make those jokes
and I've always been fairly sensitive to
this only because I have a little bit
I've read a little bit about what it is
to be chinese-american country it's not
easy and hasn't been until very recently
remember when in India is he crazy rich
Asians when those when they came into
the hotel and the hotel maitre d was
very rude to that
that was a reality that's what Chinese
people dealt with all the [ __ ] time
and then they got to a point where they
had a lot of money and trying to earn
their right in place in the world so I
understand that people are very
sensitive
once again this guy Shane gills is not
the bad guy I don't think he's racist
and we have to be careful keep going
after the people like this if he's the
bad guy everybody's the bad guy
Engineering says he's for the record
Thank You Andrea he doesn't believe you
should lose his job there you go I like
that that's really this is a part of the
best Thank You manager yang previous
referred to yang as a Jew [ __ ] [ __ ] in
episode of your last podcast that must
be it because I remember I was you can't
they said you changed you or somebody
that someone said articles captain
referring to the comedian saying
something about yang as like a Jew [ __ ]
I don't know I couldn't find a footage
from it though so that from what I saw
if that was it but I I just saw that
podcast I don't think she juicer well I
saw there's no way that men should not
been sent that's how I feel
and Andrew yang agrees although Jing is
yeah that's a normal thing to call
somebody again I yeah I I got a tricky
road when you when you go back over time
what comedians say and they go dude four
years ago you said this works with
different cultures different core I'm
trying to be funny I'm a podcast and my
friend yeah can you do yeah it's it's my
problem with it is this or you make that
what do you think I feel that most
people are like if you want to go after
the bad guys find the bad guy oh that's
what I'm saying there are plenty of bad
guys Yeah right this is this is this is
not the guy to get rid of this doesn't
mean if this is um such low-hanging
fruit there are bad people and bad go
after those guys yeah I think this is a
waste of ammo I really do and I think if
you start doing this with people like
vicam and you start getting in fired
when you have to go after the real bad
guys you're not gonna be as potent no
you've used your energy yeah and the
other thing what's like that uh in
Australia I forget what she does but she
the u.s. the u.s. he's going there you
know that big Whitaker her style bender
yeah she wants to not allow the
ring-card girls
she's in in this movement how are we
gonna have rink our girls like hold on
that's the way they make money do you
think you're pushing the women's right
agenda forward who is this one who said
Sally Capps she's like the mayor Lord of
Melbourne Melbourne bring her up let me
look what she do how do you think she
looks Brian
I would imagine she wouldn't Mesa seven
a hot I would imagine she wouldn't make
the cut as a ring-card girl but let me
just take a look at her do you think
there's some weird jealousy going on -
sure ever it's not terrible but she
should she banned oil bunnies in NASCAR
there so she doesn't want but but also
that's not your [ __ ] place to do that
those girls are employed this would make
so what about playboy can you not make a
living
pose Oh hold on so are women not suppose
to use their bodies to make money I
guess I can do it
yeah Thunder Down Under yeah they're all
Australian yes I guess they're being
objectified huh cuz you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking money and food
other mouths so do you think you're
pushing the agenda forward they you know
many girls want that guy she sucks he
sucks cuz she doesn't get laid exactly
get out of here get out of here get out
you [ __ ] politician that Shane Gill
stuff my god this young man who loves
power these people want to control
everybody this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]